hablemos sobre variación directa en
inversa entonces del lado izquierdo voy
a poner variación directa la directa y
en el lado derecho pongo la inversa
entonces variación directa e inversa una
definición sencilla para dos variables
que que varían directamente sería algo
así como llevaría directamente con x si
es igual a una constante multiplicada
por equis ajá lo podemos escribir en
nuestro lenguaje como como llevaría
directamente con x así que llevaría
directamente con x y xii si esta
constante acá te parece algo extraña
solo recuerda que puede ser cualquier
número literalmente cualquier número al
que se te ocurra entonces te daré
algunos ejemplos particulares donde
donde llevaría directamente con x
podríamos decir que es igual a x aquí ni
siquiera puse el el 1 es igual acá ni
siquiera lo puse pero lo podemos poner a
otro ejemplo sería igual
a dos por equis o ye igual a un medio
por equis o ye ye igual a menos dos por
equis también eso es variar directamente
ye ye igual a menos un medio por equis
incluso ya igual api por equis ajá y por
equis o también igual a menos pi por
equis creo que aquí ya tiene sentido o
creo que ya entiendes lo que lo que es
variar directamente y para entender un
poco mejor voy a elegir algún ejemplo
concreto de estos que puse y voy a tomar
la versión positiva y la versión
negativa entonces tomemos por ejemplo
ayer igualados x
tenemos ya igualados x y veamos porque
se dice que varían directamente voy a
elegir algunos valores para x y veamos
que resulta de gea al poner ese valor de
x en la ecuación entonces si yo tengo
por ejemplo
1 y es igual a 2 por 1 eso es igual a 2
si yo tengo x es igual a 2 entonces ya
es igual a 2 por 2 eso es 4
y podemos ver crear duplicar x lo que lo
que sucede es que también duplicamos
allí cierto entonces duplicó a xy se
duplica el valor de ye y justo eso nos
referimos cuando algo varía directamente
aquí yo duplique a x y ya también se
duplicó entonces si crece x también
crece y en la misma proporción si yo
elijo valores negativos para x también
va a decrecer en la misma en la misma
escala que x que también va a decrecer
entonces veamos qué pasa si yo elijo a
ye igual a menos 2 x menos 2 x no mejor
a menos 3 x entonces pongo aquí la x
ilife y ok si x es igual a 1 y es igual
a menos tres hojas y si x es igual a 2 y
es igual a menos 6 menos 3 por 2 es
igual a menos 6 nota que aumentamos a x
por 2 cierto ya lo pongo en el mismo
color verde que lo puse allá bueno no es
el mismo exactamente pero sirve entonces
aumente a x por 2 y lo mismo pasó con
jeff se duplicó así que para llegar de 1
a 2 multiplicamos por 2 para llegar de
menos tres a menos 6 multiplicamos por 2
aumentó proporcionalmente y si queremos
ir en la otra dirección digamos vamos a
intentarlo con qué te parece x igual a
un tercio si x es igual a un tercio
entonces y es igual a menos tres por un
tercio
es igual a menos 1 aja nota que de 1 a
un tercio lo que hicimos puede dividir
entre entre 3 y para llegar de menos
tres a menos uno también dividimos entre
tres cierto entonces hicimos lo mismo
sea cual sea la dirección que tienes
para x en esa misma dirección va a
variar ye a eso es lo que eso es a lo
que nos referimos cuando hablamos sobre
variación directa ahora no siempre es
tan claro porque ok el asunto no siempre
es tan claro veamos hoy voy a tomar este
ejemplo este ejemplo ya igual a menos 3x
y lo podemos manipular algebraica mente
quizás dividir entre ambos lados entre x
entonces voy a hacer eso tendríamos
tendríamos que sobre x es igual a menos
3 o también podríamos hacer lo que
acabamos de hacer dividir ambos lados
entre x y después dividir ambos lados
entre l entonces obtendríamos
obtendríamos 1 sobre x es igual a menos
3 x 1 sobre l
estas ecuaciones dicen exactamente lo
mismo puedes ver que la variación
directa no es siempre tan tan directa o
bueno siempre directa pero no es tan
clara obvia no es tan obvia sería la
palabra ahora puedes manipular esto a la
forma original también y hay otras
maneras de hecho podríamos hacer esto
dividir ambos lados entre entre menos 3
y obtendríamos menos un tercio y igual a
x y esto es interesante porque aquí esto
es el equivalente a x varía directamente
con jeff ajá o x es igual a alguna
constante k por x en general es verdad
si llevaría directamente con x x varia
directamente con ye ahora no va a ser la
misma constante claro pero si será el
inverso de esa constante y ok a aunque
así están variando directamente no no
importa mucho ahora vamos con variación
inversa porque ya vimos bastante de
variación directa aquí podría ir
cualquier variable cierto a ibm y
entonces sería x
con nm varía directamente con ene oem es
igual acá alguna constante cada por n
pero ahora trabajemos con variación
inversa entonces tenemos tendríamos
alguna ye igual a alguna constante k por
multiplicada por 1 sobre x entonces en
lugar de cerca por x ahora tenemos k por
1 sobre x algunos ejemplos serían igual
a 1 sobre x oye igual a 2 por 1 sobre x
lo cual es claramente 2 sobre x también
por ejemplo ye igual a un tercio por 1
sobre x lo cual es igual a 1 sobre 3x o
también ya igual a menos 2 sobre x y
vamos a explorar la variación inversa de
la misma manera que exploramos la
variación directa así que voy a elegir
digamos allá igualados sobre x entonces
ya igualados sobre x y pongo la misma
tabla tenemos los valores de x aquí y
los valores de jane ok si x es igual a 1
y es igual
si x es igual a 2 y es igual a 1
entonces si yo estoy multiplicando a x
por 2 si lo incrementó por un factor de
2 que sucede con ye lleva a decrementar
en un valor de 2 también entonces nota
que note la diferencia aquí si yo
aumento a x aumenta y en la misma escala
baja y acá si yo aumento a x entonces el
valor de lleva a decrecer en la misma
escala que x y en la otra dirección si
por ejemplo x es igual a un medio
estamos bajando en x estamos yendo de 1
a un medio vemos que que lleva a
aumentar porque 2 dividido entre 1 entre
un medio es igual a 4 ya puedes ver que
aumenta y en general lo que está aquí
pasando es que están haciendo lo opuesto
cierto están variando inversamente de
ahí está el nombre variando inversamente
y claro no siempre tiene esta forma
bonita y entendible pero pero se puede
acomodar de muchas maneras
y no dejará de ser por eso variación
inversa por ejemplo podría podría ser
que manipulando la algebraica mente
siempre siempre que sean equivalentes
algebraica mente esto a estas otras
opciones como por ejemplo equipos
igualados estoy simplemente
multiplicando por equis tendremos la
misma tabla o a esto dividirlo entre ya
tendríamos x es igual a 2 sobre 2 sobre
james o lo que es lo mismo igual a 2 por
1 sobre y así que no está esto llevaría
inversamente con xy puedes manipular
esto algebraica mente para mostrar que x
varía inversamente con jeff ajá entonces
entonces llevaría inversamente con x
esto esto es exactamente lo mismo que x
varía inversamente con que equis varia
imprecisamente con ye y hay
hay más podríamos tomar esto y dividir a
ambos lados entre dos obtendríamos que
10 sobre 2 es igual a 1 sobre x hay
muchas cosas locas aquí en general si tú
si si tú ves una expresión que se
relacione con variables ya sea que varía
inversamente o directamente o ninguna
entonces puedes hacer una tabla de este
estilo y para valores de xy ya aumenta
entonces hablas de variación directa y
si pones valores para x donde aquí se
incrementa pero ya está decreciendo
entonces eso es variación inversa ahora
lo más sencillo es manipular estas
ecuaciones algebraicas mente para ver a
qué forma llegas si llegas a esta forma
estarás hablando de variación inversa y
si llegas a esta forma entonces hablas
de variación directa